The supercomputer architect Seymor Cray
used to say, would you rather plough a field
with two strong oxen or a 1,024 chickens.
Cray preferred computers with fewer, more
powerful processors. He liked the oxen.
In this class, we will take the side of the
chickens.Modern computing products are like
the chickens. They have hundreds of
processing minds harnessing that power
requires a different way of thinking than
programming a single processor.
In this class, we will teach you how to program
the GPU. More importantly, we will teach you to
think about programming through a parallel lens
I am John Owens and I will be teaching this
class with Dave Luci from Nvidia. In this class
we will learn about parallel programming by
coating up a series of image processing
algorithms such as you might find in Photoshop
or Instagram. And we will be able to implement
these on high-end GPUs, even if you do not
have one at home yourself. I am looking forward
to seeing you in class.